okay Martin asks I have a question about
subscription pricing for a consumer
service my business is golf stats coach
do you have any resources insights or
methods about how to get the right price
for a service okay this is just basic
testing and I would look at comparable
software out there and what you'll find
is if it's a consumer product you're in
people's mind is already embedded twelve
dollars a month or fifteen dollars a
month for my streaming service obviously
something like Disney Plus came out with
a ridiculous introductory price of like
seven dollars but the lowest cost that I
think these services wind up being is
five bucks a month sixty dollars a year
if something's five bucks or sixty
dollars a year people don't even think
about it's just a snap purchase right
which is why Disney I think came out
with that introductory pricing that was
ridiculously well they didn't want
people to think about it now you get to
ten twenty bucks a month
let's just put let's just say ten
dollars a month we'll double the five
when you get to ten dollars a month at
$99 a year people need to get value from
it or they're gonna cancel because it
starts to feel like well it's a hundy
it's a hundred bucks you know it feels
more meaningful than just five bucks a
month ten bucks a month feels annoying
if you're getting hit every month and
that's one of the big secrets is you
want to offer people the $5.00 a month
or $78 a month pricing if they pay for
the year so you really want to lower the
churn by having people pay yearly if you
do it every month that means 12 charges
a year that means 12 chances for people
to unsubscribe and turn 12 cognitive
moments that the consumer has to say am
I getting value from this or not it's
much easier to pay for the year for calm
or steezy
or use ition and say you know what I'll
get to it at some point I'll play that
guitar at some point yeah and that's the
much better approach and you know in
golf you do get a little bit of a
premium because you know people are
going out there and spending five
hundred dollars on a club or three
hundred bucks on a club whatever it is
so and going out and playing golf is you
know a couple hundred dollars every time
you go out so that's a pretty amazing
group of people so there are some
exceptions where if you're doing golf if
you're doing poker training or a poker
app you could charge more because
there's more at stake and so you'll just
have to test it
and I think testing is the best way to
test it just copy other people's tests
because they've already done them so I
would just look at what comm is doing I
would look at what steezy is doing a
look at what fit bod is doing I would
look at musician and I would go down the
list of top subscription apps in the App
Store in iTunes and I would just copy
how they price things and you want
people to not have to think about it and
you want them to pay you those are two
critically important points
[Music]